[Music]
United three six seven preparing for
takeoff please advise copy that three
six seven standby
[Music]
you are one of the brightest students I
have ever had and you are failing my
class do you hear about this flight
operations were temporarily suspended
this afternoon after reports of
mysterious aircraft hovering upon the
airport I'm gonna need the footage from
this entire facility I want all those
passengers in conference room a no way
it's way bigger when I was a kid I saw
something
these lights outside it wasn't a drone
the guy on TV was like you don't
automatically jump to the most extreme
explanation this isn't some textbook
problems it's more complicated than
anything you've ever seen before this
terminal is crawling with federal agents
why would they still be here if they
figured out what it was we need to shut
him down the FBI is monitoring our
computers
why can't I see this before think it's
some sort of signal that's binary
they're using math is a way to
communicate and if I'm right he's coming
back
[Music]
there's an opportunity to take a giant
leap forward everything is riding on it
one of the most important questions in
the world is there a god what happens
when we die
are we alone in the universe if anyone
answered any one of those questions it
would change everything
[Music]
[Music]